the title of your next lecture will be
an apology for the law within this
context why did you choose this project
for your next section because I'm very
for quite a lot of work and I want to
apologize for that
given my goal I mean my goal here is to
talk about how the world has problems as
they share income and I can show other
views architecture music commerce work
environment where it's obvious it's
obvious that people take into account
what happens beyond their own Shores and
they produce things that are used beyond
their of insurance and blow-off there is
sometimes a political debate less among
the technical people but more that maybe
we should just look to the law in our
own country and always apply it to our
own country not look about anything else
that goes on before I want to say of
course you have to look abroad in many
cases not at all amen and I want to
explain where that is how that is why
there is much more similarity to our
other fields that you might think at
first lands and I'd say while I talk
about that and your give away the answer
because there is necessary to preserve
the rule of law to do that and the rule
of law is important for many reasons
some of which I will mention in one of
hu marriage but do you think it is fun
of Christ yes of course all you often do
is turn on the television set maybe now
you're just look at the internet screen
you will see people in the world who and
solve their problems without goal isn't
very pleasant
if it causes much pain and suffering and
death to people who lives in such places
so obviously it takes effort for care
and participation for those who live in
countries that are lucky enough to have
a rule of law and preserve it and to use
it as the superior way to solve many of
the problems that are now troubling us
all